Speaker 1: But I will say one other
thing. Speaking of indictments and
Donald Trump and criminal charges and all
that, new polls have come out this week,
multiple new polls showing that the indictment
from last week is not helping Donald Trump at all.
Now, shortly after the indictment, about a day or
two later, Donald Trump got on truth social and,
you know, he attacked the prosecutors as
he's been doing. But he also mentioned in
one of those posts on true socials. My my
poll numbers have gone through the roof.
And to an extent with the Republican
base, they absolutely have.
But if you're just going to cherry pick the
data, then sure, you can pretty much use it
to prove whatever you want to prove. So you got
to look at the bigger picture, which is something
Donald Trump doesn't want people to do because
his approval rating ever since those indictments
came down has tanked four points dropping from an
already historically low 29%. All the way down to
25%, according to a new ABC News Ipsos poll. But
what's more important with this polling data,
along with other polling data that recently came
out from CNN, is that independents are the ones
who have effectively turned against Donald Trump.
Let me read some of these numbers for you here.
According to the ABC poll, 54% of independents say
that Trump should have been charged with a crime.
57% say that he intentionally did something
illegal. Now, it is a little weird that those
two numbers are not equal, which means you have
more people, more independents saying, yes,
he definitely did something illegal
and he did it illegal on purpose.
But you only have 54% that say he should have
been charged. So there's a 3 to 3% gap there.
That makes no sense. So 3% of independents think,
oh, yeah, he totally intentionally broke the law,
but he shouldn't be charged. So that's
a little weird. Again, you would expect
those numbers to match up, but they don't. But
either way, you have a majority of independent
voters. And that's the key that do believe
not only that Trump should have been charged,
but that he definitely intentionally did something
illegal. The CNN numbers are even worse for Trump.
62% of independents in the CNN
poll approve of the indictment.
Of course, Democrats, Democrats. I don't know why
I said that awkwardly. Democrats overwhelmingly
support it. Republicans overwhelmingly reject it.
So what does this matter? Right. Trump's approval
rating goes down four points, obviously very
bad for him as he tries to run for president.
But it's the numbers with the independents that
are important. Because, yes, Trump's poll numbers
within the Republican Party, they're doing great.
They're doing better than they have in the last
year. The problem Trump faces is that he hasn't
attracted any new voters, and that's the key. See,
Trump cannot win a general election with
just his MAGA base. He can win a primary
with at 100% like no question about that. And
right now, based on the numbers, it looks like
he may be cruising to an easy victory with that.
But when it comes time for the general election.
He's repulsed. The independents. He's
repulsed the moderate Republicans.
Right wing groups have already been holding focus
groups since the indictments came down. And sure,
there's plenty of them who say, nope,
this is actually made me more likely to
vote for Trump. But some Republicans say this
sealed the deal. I'm not going to support him.
So even the people who came back to support
Trump after saying, no, I'm done with him,
Wait, no, I'm going to come back. Those aren't
new Trump voters. Those are previous Trump voters
who are just coming back into the fold. So they
voted for him in the past and now they're saying
they're going to vote for him again. So that
doesn't count as a new gain for Trump. That's
why these numbers are important. We have to
fully analyze them and realize what they're
telling us. And right now, they're telling us
that those true moderates, the independents,
the swing voters out there in America, they want
nothing to do with this guy. They're sick of it.
They're saying he's too caustic. He's
too bombastic. He's got too much baggage.
I mean, he's not due back in court until December.
But under New York state law, the prosecution has
to be ready to go to trial within six months of
issuing the indictments. So even though he's not
due back till December, at that point, the
prosecution legally has to be ready to go.
So we could get a trial. During the Republican
primary, we could get a trial before the 2024
election. And that's not going to play well with
those moderates and independents, because we're
also talking about a New York jury. Donald Trump
is not well-liked up there, so he doesn't stand
a very good chance of being successful, maybe on
appeal, but probably not with the initial trial.
And the independents are already sick of
him. They're ready for him to go away. His
poll numbers continue to get worse no matter
what he says. He's in trouble and he knows it.
We have to take a quick break. I am Farron
Cousins. You can follow me on Twitter,
Instagram and Facebook. I'm at fair and balanced
and subscribe to the Ring of Fire YouTube channel
YouTube.com slash the Ring of Fire. We'll be
right back with more on the David Pakman show.